dans les terriens du dimanche sur ces 8
qui a fait naître une énorme police
avant le débat bessat to see donc
chroniqueuse dans l'émission des
terriens du dimanche avait déjà annoncé
sur son compte twitter que l'émission ne
s'était pas spécialement bien passé ce
soir les terriens le moment le plus
douloureux que j'ai eu à vivre en télé
face à un zemmour hargneux insultant et
agressif envers moi toujours très
affecté d'ailleurs et ça n'a pas manqué
alors qu'ils étaient sur un débat
faut-il franciser les prénoms eric
zemmour a craqué quand il a parlé à la
chroniqueuse absatou on vous a résumé la
faire si vous n'avez pas suivi
ça a été un déferlement sur les réseaux
sociaux on en parle juste après c'est le
quart d'heure sans filtre c'est parti
hier soir à 19h25 sur ces huit été lancé
la nouvelle saison des terriens du
dimanche thierry ardisson recevait entre
autres le polémiste eric zemmour venu
faire la promotion de son nouvel ouvrage
face à lui plusieurs chroniqueurs dont
hapsatou sy et c'est avec cette dernière
qu'un gros accrochage a eu lieu
normalement
chez moi on doit donner des prénoms dans
ce qu'on appelle le calendrier c'est à
dire les saints chrétiens
ah bon on a eu tort voudriez donc je
m'appelle comment corinne mais il s'agit
là de la partie diffusée de l'émission
car les échanges auraient continué en
plateau et aurait été beaucoup moins
cordiaux hapsatou se serait fait
insulter par eric zemmour après la
diffusion de ce passage elle s'est
exprimée sur les réseaux sociaux pour
indiquer qu'elle ne comptait pas en
rester là
je vous informe réfléchir a déposé
plainte contre monsieur zemmour sur le
plateau j'ai subi des insultes graves
ainsi que mes parents très affectée par
la violence de la scène que j'ai eu à
vivre et que vous n'avez pas vu ce soir
tu réfléchis à quitter l'émission alors
selon vous faut-il encore invité eric
zemmour alors donc elle a dit vous avez
vu son twitter elle réfléchit à quitter
l'émission donc la question que vous
pose faut-il encore voilà invité eric
zemmour sur les plateaux de télé alors
ceux qui sont pour son la guerre andré
bercoff qui nous a rejoint merci andré
d'être avec nous merci beaucoup
voilà parce que franchement il fallait
avoir aussi le courage de venir vous
êtes journaliste et écrivain vous êtes
plutôt du côté voilà de ceux qui sont
pour et eric zemmour et pour l'inviter
encore sur les plateaux télé
vous êtes pour l'inviter oui mais
attention ils ont très peur de mercy et
intervenants contre françois durpaire et
est un ami qu est historien et l'un des
consultants les plus célèbres de france
voilà les deux je suis très content de
vous voir andré et et françois parce que
je sais que ça va être un débat animé
vous n'êtes pas forcément le meilleur
ami d'eric zemmour vous êtes plutôt
contre le fait qu'il soit trop invité
sur les plateaux
alors on va revoir d'abord avant d'en
parler on va voir déjà les plus gros
dérapage d'eric zemmour parce que on va
voir ça et puis après on va revenir sur
ce dérapage parce que c'est vrai que ça
tout ça a été très très dur pour elle je
vous le dis j'ai des news voilà et je
peux vous dire que ça a été chaud en
2008 eric zemmour avait eu un violent
clash avec ramzy
eric zemmour a sous-entendu 'crise'
n'avais jamais lu de livres ce qui a
énormément énervé mon poto un petit prix
on s'est trop de gens ont peut pas
parler normalement sans faire du name
dropping tout bas c'est d'avoir lu des
livres
excuse moi d'avoir lu des livres vous
entendez quoi avec ça vous sous-entendez
que moi je n'ai pas le vous le
sous-entend riadh essid était bon qu'il
voyait 0 petit rire hypocrite
ce gaz sera
j'ai beaucoup lu et s'est produit en
cité et que j'ai le teint basané qui
n'est pas lui j'ai alors pour revenir
donc ça c'était pour montrer un autre
dérapage mais absatou ci a continué sur
twitter ladino gagnera pas cette fois
j'ai tous les éléments en ma possession
ils ne s'en sortira pas indemne et pour
mes parents et mon identité insulté ce
soir j'irai jusqu'au bout quelles que
soient les conséquences à bon entendeur
interrogé dessus ce matin sur lci
zemmour est resté campé sur ses
positions aucune excuse pour absatou
regard des iapps à toucy avec un prénom
comme le vôtre ne fait pas partie de la
république non j'ai pas dit ça on ne
parle pas on est on est on est pas dans
leur sens parce que c'est pas un prénom
ce n'est pas dans la france c'est pas un
prénom français
c'est l'impression du calendrier les
saints chrétiens gsm ex-ps exactement
quand même la violence inouïe de dire à
quelqu'un
le prénom vous avec le prénom vous
portez vous ne faites pas partie de moi
bon je trouve beaucoup plus violent des
gens qui donnent à leurs enfants parce
que c'est pas elle que j'accuse en
l'occurrence ce sont ses parents qui
donnent à des enfants des prénoms qui
sont étrangers à l'histoire de france
alors qu'eux ils veulent que leurs
enfants vivent en france pour vivre en
france il faut s'assimiler à l'histoire
de france à la culture française
alors donc ça a continué toute la
journée on va quérir kerhardy sont donc
la tâche est de pas de tir à dix on a
publié un communiqué concernant la
séquence de eric zemmour et absatou la
séquence de l'émission les terriens du
dimanche du 16 septembre à laquelle fait
référence absatou ci a été délibérément
coupé au montage selon les instructions
du service juridique de ces huit donc
bravo assez vite quand même d'avoir
coupé la séquence par ailleurs lors des
précédents passages d'eric zemmour sur
la chaîne ces propos avaient déjà fait
l'objet de condamnations judiciaires
constantes hapsatou sy ciel souhaite
quitter l'émission il faut que j'en
informe rapidement
thierry ardisson stéphane simon donc ses
producteurs hapsatou elle a réagi très
étonnée je travaille avec thierry depuis
plus d'un an il me connaît connais mon
numéro
je suis très affecté par son silence
depuis jeudi et ce communiqué
j'en prends acte mais bon pas grave ce
n'est rien face à la violence de ce que
je vis alors est ce que vous pensez
qu'il faut encore invité eric zemmour
sur les plateaux vous vous dites contre
françois durpaire contre on peut dire un
mot du prénom l'histoire du prénom c'est
quand même assez violent c'est vrai
et rés c'est pas français comme très
dense et rx et suédois oui d'ailleurs
cyril sacékripa elle ça s'écrit de zèle
en français donc votre nom il est
d'origine grecque est bienvenue je suis
tranquille je m'appelle françois ouais
ça veut dire fond c'est non mais ce
qu'il faut quand même lui expliquer
c'est que les séparant absatou sont
d'origine sénégalaise sa porte une
histoire l'islam en fait c'est difficile
de débaptiser parents de kader et ça a
un nom c'est un épithète du prophète
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose son
deuxième mois et fait un sens très très
fort zinédine par exemple c'est la
beauté de la religion est ce qu'on va
dire zinedine vous faites vos parents
font honte à la france vous n'êtes pas
vraiment fou c'est zinédine n'est pas
français vous trouvez que c'est qu'eric
zemmour a créé trop loin là où bat 14
siècles de présence musulmane et juive
en france donc lui dis c'est pas
français mais qui dit y a pas de police
alors alors j'aimerais qu'on vienne lui
reste-t-il encore adulé l'eczéma ou sur
les plateaux
ce que vous dites oui oui d'abord je
vais dire géraldine maillet après je me
rendrai andrée que tu dis oui
alejandro est fatigué mais non mais
c'est pas l'un attendez moi je vais vous
dire je m'étonne que vous posez cette
question
ah oui franchement syrie non il moi je
veux dire faut-il inviter eric zemmour à
la télévision c'est dire qu'il ya des
gens qui doivent être interdits de
télévision et je pose la question d'un
homme avait raison mais je veux dire
'attendez d'abord et reese et moi ça me
faire et quand on dit les sources sur
tous les plateaux
rappelez-vous que rtl étaient tous les
jours maintenant il est une fois par
semaine un deuxièmement il était à paris
je vois que c'était paris 1er proprement
faut on peut pas dire que eric zemmour
soit traité comme un roi andré dion je
vais juste vous dire un truc moi un
petit je veux dire un truc au
téléspectateur moi je vais vous dire un
truc parce qu'il ya une hypocrisie aussi
un kéké l'attend
voilà je vous le dit eric zemmour il
fait de l'audience eric zemmour effet
d'audience et les producteurs de
l'émission vous diront ah bah moi je
suis content sam dg eric zemmour je vais
voir comment je vais cartonné en
audience essais libres qui se
les meilleures ventes de lille ils se
servent de lui il était le chroniqueur
sur france ô et je sais de france quoi
sur moi c'est de la diversion dans mes
lauriers se servent aussi de lui je vous
le dis on va le mettre sur des sujets on
sait qui va déraper et rêver et nous
derrière celle ont récolté les fruits
peuvent s affairent juste un mot sur les
prénoms allait prendre parler de huy a
parlé de zinedine zidane
oui mais je vous signale que zinedine
zidane les deux prénoms de ses enfants
ce sont des prénoms français et italiens
alors tu es kouyaté n'a rien ferez vous
êtes d'accord avec eric zemmour ses
propos sur hapsatou sy non pas du tout
mais parce que je pense que chaque
famille a le droit et le devoir de
donner le prénom à ses enfants comme il
veut c'est pas le fait qu' elle
s'appelle apsad ou qu'elle ait peur
française bien sûr c'est grotesque
alors ya le magal compagnon daxatou city
a pris sa défense j'ai honte donc et
vincent cerrutti gironde pour monsieur
zemmour je suis désolé mais je
n'appellerais pas la mère de ma fille
corinne c'est donc le dimanche le dîner
de cons je pensais que c'était le
mercredi je ne comprends plus rien alors
oui quand on invite la haine ont
déclenché la n ont pour moi franchement
attire rdc bien celui requis pour sauver
une émission franchement en berne de 8
ans ménagères pas marché ça lui même est
un marché de dia a assisté mais a voulu
trop gens qu'il aimait pas thierry non
mais a voulu vraiment créé voilà un
débat de haine
une fois là-bas tout est et lui il
savait très bien que ça partirait comme
ça que ça créerait la haine et le buzz
il espérait de l'audience c'est tout ce
qu'il a fait et du coup il a pas eu
d'audience
honte à lui c'est aussi alors que
géraldine alors vous ce soir le fonds a
effectivement je trouve que eric zemmour
est depuis maintenant des années en roue
libre est complètement perdu dans son
délire identitaire assimilationniste
enfin moi personnellement sur le fond je
le combats de début jusqu'à la fin
alors il a eu d'ailleurs quad et je vous
entends je conçois moi je pense qu'en
fait il faut combattre ses idées il faut
l'invité sont ils pas des idées on la
sauve par ailleurs parce que il ya une
tradition française qui fait que par
exemple le racisme n'est pas une idée en
france même si vous êtes il est condamné
non mais il ya des
alors je vous pose des illuminations
raciste si apple a été condamné par la
justice pour discrimination et montre
aux téléspectateurs pourquoi eric
zemmour a été condamné
c'était pour ce fait il a été condamné
pour incitation à la haine après avoir
expliqué que la plupart des trafiquants
de drogue étaient des noirs ou des
arabes
on a les images regarde quand par
exemple certains employeurs s'adresse à
des directeurs des agences intérim leur
dit s'il vous plaît je ne veux pas
d'arabes et de noirs
injuste quand même on connaissait le
pays' on croit et non pas le droit non
c'est non c'est un des lignes c'est un
délit puni par la loi sur les
statistiques de délinquance des mineurs
je pense qu'il y à entre 90 et 95% de de
noirs et de maghrébins et 92% cnpa mais
c'est ridicule c'est la réalité non pas
pour vous non pas les chiffres
alors voilà j'ai pas là donc ça je vous
ai montré pourquoi il avait été bon et
vous vous pensez qu'il faut plus invité
sur les plateaux avec des mots jamais il
doit être banni à cette commission
on a perdu des gens devaient s'unir avec
eux j'aime beaucoup andré bercoff mais
vous délirez avec tous ces gens là andré
le voulez bien sûr qu'il faut
l'interdire
il professe la haine je dirais pas qu'il
est raciste parce que ils pourraient
nous attaquer mais il a des propos qui
le sont vous savez ce qu'il a dit dans
la séquence censuré vous n'êtes pas un
enfant de la république votre prénom est
une insulte à la loi alors ses sacs à
l'entrée du spectateur on dit la phrase
qui vous plairont dit la phrase vous
n'êtes pas un enfant de la république
votre prénom est une insulte à la france
ça peut d'ailleurs être attaquée parce
que c'est un terme de mépriser base est
parfait mais quand on dit ça sur platon
doit être interdit jamais ça tout s'est
arrangé elle a dit je vous informe
réfléchir à déposer payer 2 contre
monsieur zemmour sur le plateau j'ai
subi des insultes graves ainsi que mes
parents très affectée par la violence de
la scène que j'ai eu à vivre et que vous
n'avez pas vu ce soir je réfléchis à
quitter l'émirat qui tenait alors oui
c'est n'importe quoi
alors qu'andré d'accord mais alors je
vais vous dire ce qui est n'importe quoi
d'abord je trouve que quelqu'un comme
gilles verdez wiki eux qui n'est pas
tjrs a pas le les neurones d'un enfant
de deux ans et demi dire que quelqu'un
il faut l'interdire
complètement je vais vous dire un jour j
si un jour vous dire des conneries au
vous interdira cette lettre et je vais
vous dire et vous serez très très marie
la liberté d'expression monsieur verdez
elle ne se divisant la has à ce que
quand on commence et ollon d'outils et
bien enlever la liberté expression
connaissement jamais qu'on a su que j'ai
arrêté quand on insulte je suis radieux
statut et la mutualité incitent à la
haine ça ne veut rien dire dit moins que
si c'est les gens qui se font massacrer
un peu partout vous croyez mais est ce
que est ce que ces gens là qu'un rapport
jan quel rapport aujourd'hui il ya la
différence des noirs l'escalavage alors
dit rihanna tu as tu voulais rassurer
puisque toi sata deux poids deux mesures
je pense que thierry c'est ce qui fait
en invitant eric zemmour il sait que ça
va déraper à la roue à l'autre
voilà ça c'est certain décision de
producteurs est ce que cette séquence
n'a choqué toi non ça va intéresser je
trouve que absatou ne sait pas ne s'est
pas débattue elle aurait dû se battre
résolu l'équivalent d'à reçoit des états
unis ça peut arriver aux états unis vous
avez le premier amendement
c'est à dire comme comme comme le dit
andré on a le droit de tout dire aux
états unis vous avez des tops chaud vous
avez des nazis avec les brassards nazis
oui vous avez en face les représentants
de la communauté juive et les gens ça
super et le peuple et l'applaudît les
nazis les a applaudis l'europe n'entende
à comment je fais demain les habitations
c'est une heure françois de la france
depuis 1880 c'est aussi vieux que la
baguette ou le a une tradition de
tolérance qui est inscrit dans le code
civil
mais le code pénal et ça ça serait
jamais fait en france on découvrit la
luna vient poser question andré bercoff
françoise nyssen wii u 10 minutes la
culture vingt six mois ce qui est avec
mépris total les mâles blob
on en a marre de voir les mâles blancs
depuis 50 ans oui hétérosexuels ont très
dur à tracer
c'est ça la justice et deux sont
heureusement le racisme anti blanc n'ont
en l'occurence il n'a pas été puni alors
les chefs est ce que si je vous dis la
mer est ce que si cette séquence alors
où line avait était dans notre émission
est ce que qu'on sait que ça aurait été
arrêté je crois cent fois pire maïs et
du direct nous c'est du direct on est
mené sera pas été coupé racé comme
jamais j'en avais passé nick ham annonce
on serait déjà plus là je mets 6,10 à
6,10 à sur le plateau moi je le gifle
mais c'est n'importe quoi
il s'agit vous pouvez pas dire ça si je
viens comme gilles côté prof de
journalistes une autre en tentant de la
liberté de la presse la liberté de la
parole en qu en toi bien séché c'est à
dire ça mais doit s'assurer qu'elle
garde après la liberté de la presse en
france
françois le prêt elle est très précise
elle est définie par la loi de 1881 à
fait a dit la liberté de la presse
s'arrête au racisme à l'incitation à la
haine
on se calme et on entre un père bernard
montiel
[Rires]
moi je m'en fous
moi je m'en fous mais je n'ai vu les
tensions du vercors je les ai vus je les
aimais sa soirée alors vous savez quoi
alors si mal généralement côte d'ivoire
s'est passé vous savez quoi je faisais
ça commence avec rami je pense à fsa
tout qui a beaucoup souffert d'abord
depuis longtemps du racisme il ya une
séquence aussi dans l'émission où on
voit vincent qui discute avec elle qui
est en train de lire un sage pas sentir
utile afin d'élire tous les messages de
haine qu'elle reçoit tous les jours
voilà c'est ignoble
dès demain l'avenir gernez alors il
faudrait vous gifle et coluche mais
quand coluche disait coluche disait on
n'a pas le droit de dire la france aux
français c'est très gros délire et
d'humoriste vous délirez la même temps
les chéris la liberté d'expression ne
s'arrête pas à vos caprices la liberté
d'expression et antichrist conneries on
est très contents d'entendre vos
conneries quelquefois je pourrais dire
le tribunal de l'intelligence pourrait
condamner de leurs mots pour son dernier
rôle justifier un peu d'oxygène pour
andré
la logar c'est la maison qui fait un
débat mais sous la bouteille d'oxygène
un délire ah bah ouais enfin j'aimerais
avoir
j'aimerais avoir l'avis des
téléspectateurs qui nous plaît et
jardinent mallié d'abord alors oui
doit-on et non non et encore a dit eric
zemmour sera pas tout et les non tu
faisais écoute moi bien
[Applaudissements]
retrouvez les tops pétain vous y
incarnez 4,95 à bertoua
[Rires]
professeur de journalisme ce conte
[Applaudissements]
mais ce n'est pas dans nos manières
je pense que les gens ont beaucoup
compris êtes vous d'accord avec les gens
savent ils sont débiles enfin que ça y
est tu nous as it gets cyril pour
dénoncer la colonne il faut qu'elles
s'expriment voilà c'est tout non loin de
nier la shoah sur un plateau télé c'est
pas au nom de quoi
je trouve que c'est enfin mathieu a
raison je trouve que c'est
intellectuellement totalement malhonnête
le montage de thierry ardisson merci
tout élément pas sa chroniqueuse qui
l'envoie comme ça ça ils font ce qu'ils
veulent les mecs web on donne notre
amérique idéologiquement c'est
totalement malhonnête ce qu'il a fait
cette chronique juste vous dire qu'on ne
cherchez pas ce buzz là pour ce débat
aujourd'hui pour parler de l'émission
que quelqu'un ose me dire le contraire
aujourd'hui voilà on s'est servi de la
haine pour essayer de faire un buzz sur
des missions pardon alors il ya encore
réagi ce soir la vidéo mais non on en a
une sur bfm il a réagit encore eric
zemmour ce soir regardez moi ce que vous
réagissez à l'annoncé de la plainte de
l'entrepreneuse et chroniqueuse
ah ben c'est tout si je m'appelle accès
à tous je suis française et vous lui
avez répondu que sa mère avait eu tort
qu'elle aurait dû l'appeler corinne et
que dans le fond c'était pas assez
français et pour elle c'est le moment le
plus douloureux dit-elle en télévision
écoutez d'abord je tiens à vous dire que
ce n'est pas moi qui ait provoqué cette
polémique doublement d'abord c'est pas
moi qui ai mis le sujet sur la table
c'est thierry ardisson et ce n'est pas
moi qui ai parlé du prénom qu'on vienne
pas me dire que c'est une de mes
obsessions que c'est moi qui ai lancé la
polémique pour lancer la pauline c'est
tout ce que je voulais préciser alors
qu'est ce qui se passe mais c'est ce
qu'on disait oui pourquoi
mais que ardisson à attin et le sait
mais il fait du produit
en promo pour son dernier bouquin bien
sûr aussi été facile de commander en
syrie oui bah tu fais la promo ça va ça
numéro 1 des gens très bien le faire
passer pour quelqu'un de bâillonner
c'est là que deux bayonnais est ce qu'il
faut il a perdu trois éditions sur
miroir 24 24 sur tout les plateaux télé
avec andré il y as bossé il y ait
beaucoup parce que je vous le redis
encore les produits parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils vont faire du salarié beaucoup
plus souvent s'il accepte et où il est
beaucoup plus là il pourrait être en
avait quand même coupé les ponts peau
est fine et voici mon côté serveur et
des issas servir je suis reliques de ses
huit civils et a bien fait son boulot
que les producteurs ne responsable à
celui demandé à arrêter là c'est vrai ou
pas la chaîne avait cédé faire de
l'audience
tu m'as un juif et d'antisémite qui
lance le débat que tout le monde
s'engueule et tout le monde se frappent
et d'ambiance c'est lui va la télé mais
pardon calmez vous d'info mais juste
série je vais dire une chose
oui l'émission de cyril hanouna et je
suis pas là vraiment pour faire de la
démagogie facile
j'apprécie énormément que ce soit en
direct et pas coupé extrêmement est une
chose qu'il est ici
[Applaudissements]